good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy wednesday also known as
home day over here at the morning toast
theo is obviously here
jackie is here let the humping commence
let the humping begin theo knew it was
humpty he got his hair
cut he's his nails did he's looking so
stunning for hump day and it's just a
beautiful it's a beautiful way to
celebrate we've got mcplant in the back
i know by the way so i rewatched
yesterday's episode and usually i don't
re-watch the episodes because it's just
like a reminder like you are
ugly and that's just like hard for me
because i work so hard on my self-esteem
and re-watching one episode
kerplunk yeah but with our new rug and
the daylight saving like fresh sun the
sun has moved and we have our mc plant
i thought that i would watch yesterday's
episode and first of all we're
hilarious and second of all the plant
like really elevates our style
we are working on getting another one
behind jackie because i think because
now i'm jealous of your mcplan like
remember when i had like a beautiful new
york city view and you had smoke stacks
oh yeah you know this is what that's
karma that's how i feel right now i know
but like
the karma was from the original sin of
you taking the good side
speaking of um our old studio it is
worth mentioning i was just on my time
up happy one year anniversary jackie
today is the day we got evicted wow
stressful stressful times but you know
everything
happens because you know someone made it
happen and kicked you out
no here we are the phrases everything
happens for a reason yeah i know which
is like
sure you can say that in hindsight of
course
but it was frustrating then but we're
we're so much happier
now i don't know how mcplant would have
felt about like that old stifling
environment
so stifling um but i'm glad that
all of us are here we have four living
organisms on the show a lot of our
guests are take not guess a lot of our
listeners are taking bets on how long
the plant
stays alive um and so we would just love
any insight i've never had a mc plant
before like i'm not
i've had fake plants i've never had a
real one so all it's by the window their
sun all help would be appreciated
yeah we just have to water it and like
every day
yeah and i believe it comes with the
instructions because bloomscape is just
on their stuff like goonscape was made
for us like we're not mc plant experts
but we want to be this episode is not
sponsored by mcplant but the plant
is this episode is not sponsored by mick
plant you're saying
you know what i mean yeah by bloomscape
but it is from bloomscape which is one
of our new sponsors so if you're looking
for a plan a big plant you should go get
one they have all different kinds of
plants
um before we dive in because we have a
busy show for you guys today jackie and
i just wanted to take a moment
and talk about what happened yesterday
just sending our love to our asian
american toasters in the asian american
community here in america
what happened in atlanta yesterday was
so disgraceful and so disgusting and
it's so upsetting so upsetting and it's
coming off the heels this is like you
know
the the 10th thing i've heard in the
last week about attacks on the asia
community
and it's really really scary and so we
just wanted to send love to our asian
american toasters
and just acknowledge how atrocious and
painful
the events of yesterday was yeah were
excuse me i agree
our hearts are with you and we're
thinking of you yes but here at the
morning toast we aim to bring positivity
we do and that's what we're going to try
and do we're going to try we have the
fast five stories you need to know i
feel as though you need to know them yes
very we have one story that i'm actually
really excited to discuss like
a shift in gears for us and also we'll
be recapping real housewives of dallas
i caught up yesterday i had you in the
back of my mind saying this is
manufactured
and i look forward to chatting yeah um i
watched it last night as well
um yeah
i have a lot of thoughts and i look
forward to sharing them with the group
how was the rest of your day yesterday
after you left here uh
morning toes oh my god the rest of my
day was pretty good i know i know we're
sitting here like
big jokes oh sorry sorry we have new
merch shopping on thursday which we are
wearing and we just like
we're remiss devastated and heartbroken
not to share with you this is the
beautiful stunning and smart collection
claudia's wearing the sweatpants
i am wearing the crewneck sweatshirt i
have a lot to say about this collection
so just
look at my sweatshirt and then hear me
out it's so beautiful stunning and smart
it's so beautiful sunny and smart so the
material on these i feel like we
need to let people know like it's a lot
more lightweight than what we've done in
the past it's perfect for spring
so comfortable the sweatpants are so
comfortable so we will be dropping
sweatpants in the matching sweatshirt
which is what we're wearing separately
now
we have a crew neck crew neck i love
a crewn crew neck
mug sticker phone case which i have here
i know maybe caught a glimpse yesterday
but this is it
um comes in every phone imaginable um
iphone
android all the cases it's also a really
good case it's very protective it's the
same kind of case we had for the
howadarn ones
um which i love and i just am obsessed
with this bar mitzvah like 90s right
it's just like bringing me back it's
just such a
positive vibe this um yeah this font and
this
color i'm loving wearing it i feel like
it's brightening up like my whole look i
feel like it's like brightening up my
face
you know when you wear a color that like
yes elevates your look yeah
so that's how i feel about this it's
dropping on thursday that's tomorrow so
oh my god that is tomorrow huh look at
that so
crew neck sweatpants long-sleeve white
shirt the sticker i already put on my
computer i'm obsessed and i have my
morning toast and my beautiful stunning
smart sticker
um so yeah it'll be at
shopmorningtoast.com tomorrow and just
make sure to get it so you can be as
beautiful studying and smart as we know
you are
also i'm wearing a size medium in the
sweatshirt love to see it i got a size
medium in the sweatpants and i will say
i
would recommend maybe sizing down
because i think um they're just
they're baggy which i personally love
but um
they they're a little bigger than what
we've made in the past i'm wearing xl in
both and very pleased with my purchase
okay perfect that's good to know yeah
that is good to know so that'll be
tomorrow and we'll keep you know
we took some sickening photos and we'll
keep posting those on our instagram so
make sure you're following the morning
toast on instagram at
the morning toast right and also at
shopmorningtoast.com tomorrow we have
tons of other merch up on the site so
get your merch it's always a mood
booster and shout out to lauren
elizabeth
it's always a good time to shop
morningtoast.com it is and it's never
too late
actually sometimes things sell out
actually a lot of the times it's too
late making it too late
because we're just like so in demand um
okay yeah so merch what else i didn't
really do anything yesterday i watched
the real housewives of dallas and i
ordered chinese food and it was so good
and i have no regrets about my meal oh
but i got hooked on thinsters
are you familiar with the things that i
am and i can't believe that you are
familiar those are like one of those
snacks that like
seem healthy but aren't it's like a
trader joe's lie you know
and they had them at my dwayne reed and
i was like really really hungry and i
knew like when i go to duane read hungry
it's so dangerous
because like i just buy everything and i
was trying to like just get like a light
snack and i know olivia has stinster's
in her house which means like they
are kind of healthy because olivia
doesn't like have a lot of non-healthy
things in her house
it's like fake healthy yeah and so i
bought it and i'm like oh they're gonna
be like gross but like whatever they
were
so [ __ ] good like oh my god i'm
obsessed and i bought three bags
and i ate half of one and then i came
into the kitchen and all the rest were
gone because ben ate all of them
wow yeah so that's what it's like living
with ben damn
i had to eat or be eaten i ordered the
smith last night
so delicious and i've talked about those
quarter pounder cookies before
and last night i just took a whole one
down wow yeah so good
so so good but i also went to live
method yesterday like
they tortured me yeah so i guess i did
earn it
um so i guess without further ado you
think we could jump right in
i have a lot to say about a lot of
things so so we might as well get right
into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
you yes you remember we used to say that
yeah sometimes we do
there's no oh sorry today i just went
right into it
today's episode is brought to you by
pros there's no one-size-fits-all when
it comes to shampoo and conditioner
we need products that are suited for our
unique needs and don't leave us
disappointed
and thanks to our personalized pros
shampoo and conditioner we've fallen in
love with our hair again
i need to talk i need to just go off
about please go off this because i
recently got my customized
shampoo conditioner and pre shampoo mask
which i've always just wanted something
to like
be more than just my shampoo and
conditioner and you take so basic like
right but with prose you take a quiz
that is so in-depth it asks you about
like
your hair needs whether it's curly wavy
straight how often you typically wash it
does it get oily but they also ask you
like where you live and all these
environmental factors that you might not
think about
but do contribute to your hair it's such
an in-depth quiz
also you of course get to choose your
own sense that by the end i was and
when my shampoo and conditioner arrived
i was like i'm the only one who has this
shampoo and conditioner it was made for
me and is it fun to feel special
it made me feel really special so pros
knows that there is more to you than
just your hair type
pros has given over 1 million
consultations with their in-depth hair
quiz which is how we both got started
with their algorithm and over 50 billion
formula combinations pros
determined a unique blend of ingredients
to treat our exact concerns
if you're not 100 positive pro pros is
the best hair care you've had
they will take the products back no
questions asked it is a healthy hair
regimen with your name all over it
literally take your free in-depth hair
quiz and get 15
off your first order today go to
pros.com toast that's p-r-o-s-e
dot com slash toast for your free
in-depth hair quiz and 15
off again that's pros.com toast
and take our word for it it's fabulous
it is so fabulous
okay oh that's i'm waiting for something
i'm up
it's your turn okay here we go first big
story of the day
sort of unfolded last night david dobrik
apologized in a new video after a woman
accused a 2018 vlog squad member
of rape so last night david dobrik
posted an apology to his youtube channel
where he addressed rape and sexual
assault allegations against former and
current members of his vlog
squad crew dober who is widely known for
rarely addressing controversy titled the
video which is two minutes and 30
seconds long
let's talk and he turned off the
comments and likes to dislikes ratio
let's talk silence he said he wanted to
address some conversations that have
been going
on online earlier in the day insider
published an investigation that included
allegations from a woman who said that
she was raped
during the filming of a 2018 vlog squad
video that was posted on doberg's
channel
she said that she was given alcohol by
blog squad members and became intoxic
intoxicated to the point of blacking out
then she said she was involved with
in group sex with domincus zegliatis
dirty dog dirty dom that she could not
consent to
i wouldn't have read that as dirty i
would have said dirt yeah no
he's so disgusting like like he's was
the worst part of vlog squad and
like here's why you know yeah also in
february former vlog squad member seth
francois spoke out and said that he was
tricked into kissing dobrik's right hand
man
jason nash in a 2017 video uh seth said
it was non-consensual and was sexual
assault as he was under the illusion he
would be kissing model and influencer
karina kopff who would be wearing a mask
rather than nash a 45 year old man
yeah so i think we should start at the
beginning because like for the last year
first of all david hasn't vlogged in a
year but there's been a lot of rumblings
mostly from trisha paytas
and ethan klein who have this podcast
called frenemies that's really really
popular
trisha paytas used to date jason nash
and they broke up and ever since then
she's just like real she's been like
she's been
like one of the few people on the
internet talking about like her
experience
being a part of the vlog squad and how
it was like so
toxic um and for a while she was like
kind of like shouting into a void on her
podcast but she was like
and i understand she she isn't always
like the most reliable source because
she has her own controversies and she
was a part of the vlog so like i think
for a while people
just kind of disregarded what trisha was
saying but more people started to speak
out
in recent months kind of corroborating
the type of environment that tricia was
describing amongst the members
um first was seth who it's actually i i
saw
an episode of um law and otter svu
that was really similar to the situation
like it happened in a frat house
where what happened to seth was like
they blindfolded him and was like karina
who's a member of the vlog squad who's
like this gorgeous
instagram model um is gonna kiss you and
it ended up being jason who's 50 years
old a man and
kind of gross um that's just my opinion
so and
it reminded me of this lawn water
episode that i watched which is like
it's like this
a salt gray area and it's like but but
it is really really unethical
um and so that story like kind of blew
up and a couple of the vlog squad
members because there's like
15 of them like they had made their own
videos like addressing it
like giving their own receipts kind of
discrediting seth
um but it never became like a major news
story but there has been like all this
momentum
you know people talking chatter online
about david dobrik and now this business
insider
article was kind of the the big
explosion to take the story like into
the mainstream
um and this girl who spoke up what she
kind of what she alleges that
dom put on his stories they're always
like filming with random people and they
always like go to like colleges which
it's like kind of weird now that like
you think about it yeah um
to like get like extras and like it's
like scripted kind of but they play all
these games and they just need like
strangers that give away money
um so we put on his instagram that like
he needed girls and
um the girl in the story whose student
name is hannah
she um her friends are like we're like
obsessed with the vlogs one we're like
let's go let's go they need extras
and they were like dm'ing with dumb
being like we're coming we're coming and
she didn't like know who any of these
people were she didn't care but like she
just wanted to be with her friends
um and a bunch of members were there i
think they said
jeff was there and scott was there and
they were like giving these underage
girls alcohol and trisha paytas
was there that night she spoke to
business insider and she was like i left
when they were all these guys were
giving underage girls drinks because it
just like felt really wrong to me
um and then the girl woke up the next
morning and her friend was like
um i have any idea what
um her friend was talking about and she
had asked at like months
and then there's a video they vlogged
the whole night right and
a few months later she sent dom a text
and was like
this whole you know long thing very
respectful just being like
i feel so uncomfortable like i don't
remember anything that happened i really
feel like i was taken advantage of
i don't want this video out there like
can you please take it down yeah and
they did
yeah so i think people are not sharing
the clip
the clips of the video exist but people
aren't sharing it out of respect for
hannah
um but it's just like it's as as most
things are it's very layered
yes it is very layered and uh the pieces
that i saw
especially the text messages that she
heartbreaking sent to dom were
heartbreaking like
imagining from her perspective like she
describes like waking up
not knowing what happened night before
not being wearing clothes having thrown
up
in the house that she was in when she
went home her friends having sort of
like
literally carried her out right and then
on top of that trauma to there be a
video about it
and then for months later you have to
reach out to
the person who took advantage of you and
ask them to take like the whole thing is
is
so traumatic and yeah um and she's
really brave for speaking out because
yeah for up until now like david dobrik
has been like beloved they say like
he's the jimmy fallon of our generation
beloved so nobody wants to
speak out against that like it's an
uphill battle it's a losing game
yeah um and so i think she's really
brave and
it just i'm not like
when i when i heard the story i was like
surprised that it hit the mainstream but
like i've just kind of been following
this for so long and even when you watch
the videos and
i have been like last year i i've
discovered the vlog squad and i'm
obsessed with the vlogs
but there always was this like
underlying weirdness like the way they
were like
just really inappropriate and like
bullied each other there was like this
you could even from the videos not being
there like you could sense
a toxicity like it was subtle and now
these stories coming out like they don't
surprise me at all
but what does surprise me is the
response from david because it was like
so disappointing yeah i mean obviously
it was short some of the quotes
he said consent is something that's
super important to me whether i'm
shooting with a friend or i'm shooting
with a stranger i make sure whatever
video i'm putting out
i have the approval from that person he
said that he's no
he no longer films with dom he doesn't
um like approve of
that choices he said with the seth
situation i am sorry to seth i just want
to make videos where everyone who's
participating is enjoying and having a
good time
i miss the mark with that one and i'm
really sorry i truly truly am
okay so here's what i didn't like about
his video and when we talk about cancel
culture like
and i talked i talked about this a lot
in the book like but this is not
canceled these are crimes
right and so this is this is what we're
always saying here this is like the
point i really tried to drive home in my
book is like because people are dming me
like are you going to talk about david
like he doesn't deserve to be canceled
like he's so nice
and there's just such a big difference
here like and i feel like his response
was a really shitty response for someone
who had like tweets exposed like which
is not a crime it's just like
embarrassing and wrong
and i don't feel like his response even
matched
even close to the level of what he's
being accused of yeah
and i just think like when we talk about
cancel culture we really need as a
society
to separate the people who had tweaks
exposed and the people who committed
actual crimes because we are lumping
these people into like a cancel culture
category
and it's just not the same like one
person had bad judgment and another
person committed a crime
yes i agree he also um said that i've
been really disappointed with some of my
friends and for that reason i have
separated from a lot of them so he's
like distancing himself
he's blaming it all on his friends right
but also in the threesome video from
what i understand and what i gleaned
from
um the article the article or the parts
that i read which the article is now
not behind a paywall they took it off
they put it on business insider prime
which is
okay good like get your coin but like
don't profit off of someone's
trauma that's true and also there was
one there was that version which i don't
subscribe to business insider so i
didn't read but there was another
version that was
a lot of the story but it was a preview
yeah but now they took it
behind off the page so apparently there
was also podcast
audio where they talked about this three
some night and there was people who were
going in and watching it to make sure
that it happened like
right so like make sure dom actually had
a threesome his friends had to go check
david's on
travis uh what's up who used to date
madeline
patch uh who hosts ghosted yes i know
it's his podcast okay is this him travis
barker or is that like the drummer
i think that's um kardashian's boyfriend
okay whatever travis
mills travis mills um david went on his
podcast and they're like chronicling the
night david's like bragging like
yeah dom wanted to have a threesome we
found some girls like we all had to go
in and check
and so he's there like filming the night
check like it's just the more you hear
about the story the more
disgusting it is yeah and so when we're
talking about like cancel
don't cancel no like this is the type of
thing like cancer culture
should be reserved for like not people
who you know
made a mistake like and said something
wrong but the person who did something
morally depraved yes and in these
instances and i
and of sexual assault there's
there's the abuser and then there are
the people who bystanders
bystanders who watch it happen like
cheer on
like it's so it's
to be one of those people like you are
not exempt from guilt whatsoever
no and that's literally what the premise
is a promising young woman is
and it's like this terrible thing
happened at a medical school and like
all the guys like who were in like the
friend group just like stood and filmed
like
it actually reminds me of it so much i
forgot about that until right now
um i agree like it's there's multiple
people who are at fault here yes of
course dom right so
having no longer filming with dom and
not being associated with him anymore
like that's
not um that's not
enough no no and it's not lost on me how
this video was two minutes and 30
seconds which is
incredibly short was put on his views
youtube channel which is brand new
he has three youtube channels david
dobrik which i think has like 16 million
david dobrik 2 which i think has like 11
million and then this new one for his
podcast
she was on the smallest one he released
it at midnight turned the comments off
it was two minutes long like
i just feel like you might as well have
not even said anything like that's
[ __ ] disrespectful
yeah but i also i don't know i feel like
that was a choice you know
like of course yes it was a choice but
it extremely intentional like that's his
thing to minimize is the short videos
i'm going to say something and
and we're expected to move on from it um
just the more i think about this story
like it's so upset my stomach
it's so upsetting and especially now
with what just happened in the uk with
sarah everard and like women are just
now speaking out about like
how much women go through like just to
like not get attacked like
what we wear what we think how we walk
what we say like and so
for this to come out while we're having
these conversations like women
especially on tick tock like it's a huge
trend
to share um to this andre day song and
it's like so powerful
to share like what i was wearing when i
was assaulted um
it's like we're having this conversation
now like this is what you're
contributing
yeah like this two minute video like you
said david dobrik is
everywhere he's you know the biggest
digital star
period yeah and so knowing that so many
people look up to him knowing that so
many
college kids so many people would really
like would love to
be in these videos and it just it's such
an abuse of the position
it's 100 and it's really upsetting
yeah and i just like i can't stress
enough like how this is not cancelled
culture
no and it was like because i got a bunch
of dm's like what are you gonna say on
the toes and like
people love him and it's hard to
deconstruct like someone you look up to
as being
not what they say they are not the
vision of like the hero you imagine
because
he built a brand off of like giving away
hundreds of thousands of dollars but
like
that doesn't mean you can create a toxic
environment and do [ __ ] like this like
but that's the image that is cemented of
him in so many people's minds 100
and if we if our generation wants to be
different from
the generation older than us the harvey
weinstein you know right me too movement
did so much to
expose these people and then so we have
new people coming up and and in
in different ways but extremely similar
ways they're doing the same thing yeah
abusing their power
yeah 100 percent so it's it's so
disappointing
so disappointing um so i'm curious to
see
like what happens next like because
at the end of the day like this is a
full-blown crime and multiple people are
guilty like is there going to be like a
policing like there's a business insider
investigation is there a police
investigation where do we go from here
yeah i'm not i'm not entirely sure but
we'll keep you abreast
abreast um okay ready for our next story
yes
emmanuel acho is revealing the sit down
between the shelves and rachel kirk
connell that never aired okay
i saw this video on emmanuel's igtv
where he talked about his favorite
conversation from the evening
that was one in which we did not know
even happened it did not even a sliver
of it make air
it was a conversation that took place
between front runners michelle young and
rachel kirk connell
um he said tv time constraints limit you
from broadcasting everything you desire
my favorite part of the one hour special
that was not shown actually
was talking to michelle early on and i
could sense the heartbreak over her loss
of a former lover and matt
but i could also sense the despair over
her loss of a former friend and rachel
based upon the photos that surfaced now
michelle had reached out to rachel but
had never heard back and so michelle was
broken over
that i sensed that over the course of
our conversation so during that next
commercial break
i called an audible i reached out to the
producers via my mic and said
hey we have to get michelle and rachel
to somehow reconcile
he said um he recapped sort of the
conversation that they had and said that
it ended
um in a very uplifting sort of way where
the two women
come back together he said it was a
beautiful depiction that i got to
witness
and for the sake of time you did not you
all did not get to witness
i could just think of so many things i
didn't need to see on that three hour
finale
and it's like oh we have time
constraints now why are we at three
hours
right oh 100 there was time first of all
there's always
time i feel like the choice not to air
this conversation that
sounds to me was a lot about healing
it's like once again the bachelor just
like is missing the mark
on what they can contribute contributing
100 you know like it it
was definitely an impactful conversation
that would have
promoted that would have promoted
healing and especially in such a
divisive time and that's in a divisive
time within the franchise like the
franchise is literally imploding because
there the chris harrison stands and the
rachel lindsay stands are at odds
and so that type of conversation could
have been so healing so
you you uniting yeah whatever
um united unifying whatever yeah thanks
um and am i surprised that they didn't
include it no am i disappointed yeah
because like that's the message we
should be sending like not more division
people you know making mistakes
forgiveness grace this word
everyone grace grace grace grace like i
would have loved to see that
conversation especially because this is
what we literally said yesterday we were
like
you know what michelle said about rachel
was super nice and they are
they were obviously friends when you
live in a house for so long with someone
and like
where i just that was missing i do and i
did feel like that piece of like a lot
of these girls do know rachel what was
their relationship with her how do
how do they find that happen and i think
that that would have been a big piece of
this puzzle
that um would have made the special even
bet like and i love shady emmanuel acho
like putting it on
on his igtv because if we if he didn't
no one would have ever known no and
also um i saw that bree had posted that
um
she was at after the final rows they cut
her she they cut her sheet
she didn't get to be on women tell all
apparently she filmed for after the
final rose
and she wasn't on this is just like the
choppiest copy and paste season ever
like
but she was on file files so if you want
to hear from brie
check yeah still like that's so bizarre
and it's like all these actually
interesting things got cut how did we
end up with three hours of
literal trash no two hours and 45
minutes of trash some of
the 15 minutes between rachel and matt
was interesting yeah no
two and a half hours i would say yeah
but like this the message here is once
again like
bachelor producers are so not in tune
with what's necessary and with what
is good yeah okay are you ready for our
next story his name
uh demi lovato is sharing everything in
her new docu-series from kneeling
nearly dying to healing from sexual
assault
in the tell-all docuseries demi lovato
dancing with the devil which premiered
at the south by southwest film festival
on tuesday
viewers got an in-depth look at what
really happened before
during and after the singers 2018
overdose
from a detailed timeline of that
terrifying july night to the trauma
she's faced throughout her life
here are some of the most revealing
things that um
she shared in her documentary she talked
about her eating disorder that it's a
lifelong battle but she's gotten
much better she talked about dealing
with bulimia and how she felt controlled
when it came to what she ate and what
she did for most of her career
um the docu-series introduces key people
in her life including
jordan jackson her personal assistant
who made the 911 call
the morning after her overdose um
she talks about that that night
specifically
and um the events of the night and
how she was sexually assaulted by the
heroin
dealer who then left her to die
talks about um all of the health issues
that she suffered
after the fact she talks about how she
can't drive anymore because wow
her eyesight is impaired she said it's
akin to seeing sun spots
oh my god all of the permanent um damage
damage
from that night that's crazy i mean i'm
definitely gonna watch the documentary
um and i don't think demi lovato's ever
like had a problem
opening up like she's always super
honest but it really like when you watch
something in the news like
when we were reporting on that whole
overdose like you can't even imagine
how much worse that it actually was yeah
than what we were hearing
right it's it's crazy it's crazy to read
some
of them what she shares and i'm sure
this documentary will be extremely
yeah um and she has a new album coming
out and she has a song with ariana
grande on it did you
yes it's called her album's called
dancing with the devil the art of
starting over i saw that she has a song
i love that yeah she should also write a
book by that title
yeah i do think that a documentary in a
book especially if you're the subject of
your own documentary it's
the same thing just like a different
medium yeah and i'm sure one day she
will write a book and so it's a youtube
one right
i think so youtube really nails the um
celebrity documentaries
speaking of youtube something we didn't
talk about i'm wondering if you watched
new hayley bieber
youtube channel no i didn't but i have
been meaning to yeah though
who's in my bathroom yeah um kendall
kendall's in her bathroom yeah i haven't
seen it yet but i did see some clips on
youtube on tick tock going around like
making fun of her because she was like
this really solves the problem when like
you want to do a face mask but your
significant other like
like she was just like talking about
like a relatable problem that like
literally doesn't exist
and like the kids on tick tock were
[ __ ] roasting her they you can't get
away with anything they're savage
okay ready for our next story only if
it's brought to you by nuts.com
oh it is i'm lovingnuts.com i know we
have a whole thing here
oh yeah we found an incredible website
that you have to check out because
nuts.com is the best kept secret
of savvy snackers across the country so
they have a ton of high quality snacks
and if you're in
like a snack rut which i have been for
the last year because i'm literally
eating the same three things
it's good to change it up nuts.com has a
huge variety of high quality delicious
snacks like white chocolate toffee
cashews
bourbon pecans crystallized ginger honey
sesame sticks but it's not just for
lovers
sorry it's nuts.com isn't just for nut
lovers it's your one-stop
online pantry shop you know it's it's
for candy lovers too they have the most
amazing candy selection i got these
chocolate covered gummy bears the
chocolate on it's just so delectable
so delectable and i have these um
cashews that are coated in
white chocolate truffle right that are
so
bomb they're so fire i i can't recommend
highly enough if you're looking to up
your snap game
not nuts.com is a one-stop shop yeah and
also like if you're having guests over
and like you just want to do
more than just like a crudite like it
really elevates
your entertaining it really does like
you can get mixed nuts you can obviously
get the roasted salted
standard but you can also get apple pie
flavored
mixed nuts yeah the simple and
convenient way to have nutritious
delicious healthy nuts dried fruit
flowers grains and so many other high
quality foods delivered straight to your
door
they have over 4 000 products to choose
from and they have delicious healthy
kid family snacks like dried
strawberries and custom trail mix
plus all the raw organic roasted salted
and candied nuts you can imagine
even chocolate dipped the website is
very easy to navigate with great photos
of the product so you know exactly what
you're getting
and nuts.com is a family-run business
that takes pride in getting you the
freshest
products ever it is your one stop shop
plus they have gluten-free and vegan
options so anyone can chop
the delivery is super fast because most
orders ship on the same day
um so if you want to check out nuts.com
newnuts.com customers get free shipping
on their first order
when you text toes to sixty four
thousand so text t-o-a-s-t
to six four zero zero zero to get free
shipping on your first order from
nuts.com
that's toast to 64 000. check it out you
will not regret it like if there's one
thing you could trust us on
snacks it's so true okay next up is a
little sleep news
okay google's new nest hub is a smart
display that tracks your sleep quality
does google own nest like the regular
nest
does it i don't know i don't know it
would be weird if they had the same
right
product and name right so um
nest hub has the same design as as its
predecessor which i guess is
period it's a seven inch touchscreen
display but it will track your sleep so
i
but like use it you don't have to wear
anything like using your breathing and
like moving patterns
these really small um where do you put
it
like i guess you would put on your
nightstand it's google's latest smart
home device and will be able to monitor
your sleep patterns that is not too
innovative in and of itself except that
google has figured out how to do it
without a camera or any kind of wearable
device
the new nest hub comes with a function
called sleep sensing that uses low
energy radar
to monitor the breathing movement and
even the snores
of the person sleeping next to the hub
the technology will learn your sleep
patterns and provide
personalized recommendations for how to
get better shut eye here's the thing
and we live in this age of information
data data
also i just want to add before you talk
about data google says the data it
collects will not be used for ads
oh famous last words you know i'm sleep
talking in my sleep about like nuts.com
and all of a sudden targeted
no or they're like while you're sleeping
and they know you're in a deep rem cycle
they start playing ads that like
infiltrate your sleep that's like josie
and the pussycats yes
i think that this is a level of
intrusion with technology that i'm good
without but i also just like
i'm the queen of sleep well here's my
thing it's like we live in this age
where like you can just know like your
heart rate at any minute
and i just feel like certain data is
none of my business like i sleep fine
like
i just i don't know i don't need to know
that much i don't need to know how many
steps i took i don't need to know my
heart rate like i don't need to know
how many hours i snored and like what
did i say in my sleep like
some things are just not my business
yeah i agree
like humanity has gone on for so long
without us knowing the cavemen didn't
know if their partner was sleep talking
like we're fine
no or without like a tracking to track
my breathing while i sleep
usually on nights where i sleep badly i
i can probably pinpoint why that is
yeah so of course i think this is
a little extra no and there's definitely
some people who are like obsessed with
their data like fitbit
apple watch i will disagree with you on
the steps part even though like i
see none of my business it doesn't
really change anything and i also think
there was there was some information
that came out after
fitbit was so ubiquitous that it was
actually causing weight gain because
people were attributing these steps to
like calories burned
more so than you were always burning
those calories and so people were like
sort of
using that as exercise when it wasn't no
when it wasn't a new exercise that would
have been me
right so i i agree with your your thesis
but i do i do
but i also do get sort of step crazy
sometimes and then
i like find myself like just wanting to
hit these benchmarks but like
for no reason you know and honestly like
as someone who doesn't move a lot like i
just don't need that kind of negative
reinforcement like oh you only watched
500 steps today like that's none of my
business but sometimes it's super
interesting like
you know on a day where you literally
didn't leave your bed like that shows
and then also sometimes when we used to
go to like
coachella stage coach when we got lost
and we got lost and then we would go
home and we're like oh my god we did
twenty thousand steps yeah no it's like
okay it's an interesting factoid but
like i don't i'm not one of those people
who like
you know their whole day like revolves
around their apple watch you know
yes i do i do know that about you okay
um our fifth and final story
is from an uh i don't think i've ever
read an article from
this publication before the amen
american kennel brand is sharing the
most popular dog breeds of 2020. oh my
god tell me cavaliers are on there
i didn't even i did a quick scroll and i
didn't even see it like i i
i thought we were influential number one
and this isn't the same as it's been
labradors
which trees the big labs you know golden
retriever
yeah like uh
that's a golden retriever isn't that is
there a picture no it's just a list
come on we know what a lab is i think
you can have a golden lab
a yellow lab i'm just gonna look it up
really quick a labrador retriever
you know it's like airbud that is a
golden retriever
okay so you don't know retrievers
labrador retriever is what it's called
yes oh yeah oh really these are the most
popular
also but golden retrievers are number
four so there's a difference golden
retrievers are [ __ ] cute
but i do wish like golden retrievers
there were some like a breed of golden
retrievers that stayed the size
that they are when they're puppies
because they're so cute i would get one
of those but i don't have enough space
for an enormous dog
yeah plus you've already got theo okay
what's number two number two french
bulldogs which they're moving up the
rank
really i feel like after what happened
to lady gaga and like how valuable they
are in the black market they would be
moving down
well i think that what happened to her
show that it
shows that they're on like that they're
so desirable yeah but with desire
oh comes danger that's true so maybe now
they'll go down next year this was 20
20. okay
number three german shepherds let me
just double check that i know what
they're all these dogs are the same to
me german shepherd
and oh really german shepherd's big you
know what i need to stop talking about
dog breeds
negative light because we all remember
what happened with um lily reinhardt
gate 2020.
yes but don't worry top ten i think i
think you're okay number four
golden retrievers number five bulldogs
okay
number six poodles number seven beagles
number eight rottweilers number nine
german shorthaired pointers and number
ten
the dachshund ooh
and they just cracked top 10 for the
first time doc soon and i just want to
say like i do think it's related
to the toast yeah 100 um i'm just gonna
keep my mouth shut because
obviously i think some of those dog
breeds are cuter than others but i've
learned not to mess
with the dog breed community so people
feel really passionate about their
breed of choice of course and that's how
we feel about kids right now like if i
saw someone on a podcast saying like
king charles are ugly i would literally
come to their house i would literally
not care
no of course not because yes of course i
would just be like i disagree
yeah no because we live in america
where you can go on your podcast and say
whatever you want
and if someone doesn't like it they can
just leave
they don't have to announce that they're
leaving but they will
and buzzfeed will write it up and said
spread lies about you and your family
try to make you
into a murderer
in america yeah
okay i just scroll down all the way to
195 and i don't see king charles
cavalier
you know that's good because like we're
unique but yes but it also maybe means
like maybe we're not that influential
no i mean that's been the cold hard
truth for a long time
maybe i missed it but i i feel like i
would that's what i would see
gusting i know [ __ ] the american kennel
society
yeah dot com though interesting i did
think that was interesting yeah no that
is
um what was the number one golden lab
labrador retriever
got it okay i guess it's just like
that's the reinforcement that i needed
like i'm so unique
like i really feel like i'm not like
other girls you know
no i would say you're not like other
girls definitely not
um okay so let's dive into tv recap the
real housewives of dallas snoozefest
2021.
um last night okay i just have something
to say before we start
i feel bad for tiffany because she's
just like obviously like a different
type of girl
you know which is not a crime but she's
like having trouble getting along with
everyone because she's like
kind of a wet blanket okay i have a
totally different perspective
in the last two episodes i really
related to tiffany
like her wanting to be i don't think i'm
so similar to her but i understood that
feeling that she got when she jumped
into the lake and was like
this is not who i am i'm doing this for
other people but like what about what i
actually like or don't like to do and
this is not one of those things
to jump into a lake when you don't swim
in your own clothes in your own clothes
it's like you're really trying to
make it work with this the group is very
pushy yeah and she she hit her breaking
point and i completely understood and
related to that and even though like
oh my god and when she started crying in
her room and everyone started coming in
and i was literally like
leave yeah she just needed a minute
alone maybe with one friend
just to sort of vent but she and someone
said like
i think it was stephanie she was like
every day that we've been here like it's
been something for like
that for her that we have just like sort
of piled onto tiffany and like
she hit her breaking point and i feel
like on those group trips
i can 100 relate to that
then i also felt like with tiffany by
the end of her birthday party i i really
started to feel like i understood
who she is and it's funny because i
think someone else said like
we thought you were like so cool when
you came in i feel like when she came in
i thought that too where it's like
she's almost too cool for these girls
but it's actually the opposite where
it's like
she has a hard time fitting in she's
never really had
great girlfriends and i really finally
feel like i understand her
and i really really like her i
definitely feel like i understand her
too she's not like i'm
if i was in that group like i would be
like a deandra and a carrie like i'm i'm
an insane pusher i push people i'm a
drug pusher you know like
that's just what i do but i feel like i
would be like a cameron where
i have boundaries and i know how like
wearing a bathing suit under my dress i
struggled
cam right cameron struggled in the
beginning to set those boundaries and i
think that's important it's like
i want to have fun with everyone i want
to get outside my comfort comfort zone
but there are things
that i i won't do and everyone needs to
respect that and now they do respect
that about cameron yeah tiffany just
gets neat she needs to get there she
started with only boundaries then she
took away all the boundaries and she
felt like not herself
you she'll find that that medium i
completely agree i
i think she's very similar to cameron in
a lot of ways because like a few seasons
ago cameron never would have jumped in
the lake but now she like knows the
group she brought her bathing suit yeah
she's jumping in the lake
but the thing with tiffany that i'm
really struggling with is for a first
season housewife she's giving us a lot
of like personal like
family stuff work stuff and i totally
like empathized for the struggle of
working moms like i'm not downplaying it
at all but like on a reality show like i
really don't care
okay well that's on the producers i'm
sure all of the women filmed equal
amounts of time at home and they chose
her storyline
i'm going to assume it's because it was
more interesting than the others i guess
you know i mean to me that even though
it's like a lot of personal story line
from
a um new housewife i think it's more
interesting than deanna like finding her
brother
oh for sure um but i just like but the
thing is like we know d'angelo like i'm
willing to put up with that because i've
known d'andra for years now but like
with tiffany with
and we always say this like when a new
housewife comes on and like
you know gives us so much personal
backstory like
we don't care yet yeah we don't know you
yes i agree but i wouldn't blame tiffany
for that i would blame the producers
her birthday party looked really fun
even though like it was not moroccan
theme aside from the fact that they were
just sitting on pillows but other than
that a cake
it was like a kid's birthday party with
balloons and swings it was but she was
so
touched by it and i like i really feel
like this group of women
are true friends yes when they're having
like genuine
moments and for them it's like are we
gonna it's not just like we're gonna be
fine for the show it's like
we're either gonna be friends or we're
not going to be real friends which is so
much better because like
when a franchise starts and like the
women haven't seen each other since the
reunion
it's so stupid yeah so i i i didn't
agree with you that the
drama was manufactured i know but i did
feel like it was
trivial no and also like pulling [ __ ]
out of thin air like
like when brandy like just randomly at
dinner was like i'm uncomfortable around
you like it was just like not real
yes and but i also felt like um everyone
did a really good job of being like
brandy that's on you
yeah and like what are you talking about
yes but and also like when brandy like
with the pills on the boat
that's what that's exactly what i was
referring to like what yeah
but i don't think that's manufacturer
because brandy just like comes off
really
bad in those moments and brandi's just
like going through stuff especially
yesterday
oh yeah we need to talk about there's a
video i'm just gonna post it on our
instagram but then i'm like that is just
i know they're like celebrities but just
like feels really disrespectful i agree
um brian someone caught a video of brian
in a club like brian like making out
with a woman who's clearly not brandy as
she has a whole arm of tattoos
um randy looks different here yes it's
really sad but there's been rumors about
them for a while i know but there's
difference between rumors and a video
it's bad it's bad and she like just gave
birth uh-huh
but she oh right so it just made me
really sad
i know and we're not gonna get clarity
because she's made it pretty clear she's
not coming back to the show
which i think is best since there is so
much going on in her personal life but
it just leaves us wondering
yeah it does maybe he'll address it at
the reunion andy yeah and i just want to
say there's a difference between rumors
and a video teresa giudice
100 rumors and photos um
but i'm not caught up on jersey so maybe
i'll change your heart no you won't
the only other thing that happened two
other things that happened was and i'm
not christian so i can't
like decide whether um like being a
shaman is demonic or and whatever
but the only thing i didn't really like
because like i grew up in a religious
like setting and
there's a way to like have discussions
about religion without being
condescending
and you know if you grew up in a
religious setting like you know that one
girl in your grade who was just like so
obnoxious like
really you listen to music on shabbos
like shut the [ __ ] up sarah you know
yeah um and i felt like brandy was being
like a little bit of a sarah like you
don't have to agree with deandra's
choices but like don't be so
condescending yeah i felt like her
delivery
and choice and time and place was all
wrong if that's a real conversation you
want to have with deandra like not at a
birthday party when everybody's drinking
but she got all lit up
after mama d was like she that's demonic
she felt
validated in how she was feeling she
probably would have never said it or
i don't know i don't think she would
have said it if she didn't feel like oh
how i feel about that mama d agrees i'm
going to bring it out well we're
actually going to get through to the end
yes i agree she was coming off as
judgmental and i think next week when
deandra calls her at cafeteria christian
because it's like you just pick and
choose yeah
um what you want to live by i think
it'll be an interesting conversation
but like for me like when i sign on for
the real housewives of dallas like
that's the exact type of conversation i
was looking for like conversations
between sisters in christ
yeah you're my sister in christ and like
i just feel like you know leaning on
anything besides the word of god like
it's just demonic like that's what i'm
[ __ ] looking for
and i was like yes this conversation is
everything um and even though the shaman
was so weird like the fact that the
shaman does extensions like it was so
stupid and
when they were all like singing i was
literally chanting that the whole night
afterwards i couldn't get it out of my
head
um and it was weird but like whatever
works for deandra works for d'andra like
yeah i i don't like when people are all
like you know
yucking other people's yums even though
i do that all the time i totally totally
agree and like to have
to see jennifer say like thank you so
much for that that was the perfect day
it's all about what you get out of it
you know it's completely
subjective um the episode ended in the
weirdest way where basically like
deandra and her mom had this huge
blowout fight because
deandra was just trying to make a point
to someone she was like mom why did i
change my name from
callaway to simmons and she was
expecting her mom to say
one thing but her mom was like because
you knew simmons would get you further
and that's probably true but i don't
know if deandra would have asked her mom
on the spot
for an answer if you know what i mean
like yeah
or simmons definitely does get you in
the door like i don't know what simmons
means in dallas but it means
even on this show it's like she's
deandra simmons and that means a lot to
the women whereas like if she is deandra
calloway and but her stepfather simmons
like it's just it's
it's two degrees of separation right and
i think the point she was trying to make
was that like even though
you know glenn simmons was her
stepfather he was really a father to her
like and so she wanted to be his kid
and i think that's the point she was
trying to make and then mamadee was like
no cause you wanted to get your foot in
the door like
yeah that was um really crazy i
obviously didn't know that
i never thought about it i didn't know
she changed her name did you know that
yes because i knew that her and her mom
had the same last name but her mom's
husband wasn't her
biological father oh i never put it all
together so that was like a whole and i
guess then cameron was explaining that
something that she feels like insecure
about in
the community i feel that yeah i feel
that and then her mom just like
validated blew it up
yesterday her mom of like the weirdest
[ __ ] relationship no i know it got
so crazy and mama d like knows exactly
what else you're calling
indra was so drunk they all were all and
then when they sat on that
swing like of course they were gonna fly
out so you really can't be having like
conversations about like
family family christ like when
or you can it's just going to be like
extremely heated and emotional
yeah um but all in all like it was a
better episode i thought just the austin
episodes were really bad when like
trip episodes should be the best yeah
but i did think that the trip
looked pretty fun gotta stay at that
house so sickening so sickening
like i think we need a lake austin
weekend yeah also mamadi talking about
how she
hunted dog just talked and pursued her
husband was like that's the type of
thing you just like keep to yourself
uh-huh for sure but like
she's she is she is like you know what i
mean
cameron being like i don't know if
that's what we should be telling young
women
like it was just hysterical it really
really was um
and then tonight is jersey i had to
catch up on all the
jersey's really good oh you caught up
yeah oh okay i caught up
with brian we watched on vacation it was
so good i mean
it's i feel the same way every season
like it's so good but i cannot watch one
more minute of trees to juice
because i'm gonna throw my tv out the
window yeah that's how i
i've been feeling but i do believe that
this week um
tonight's episode everyone is finally in
the same room
okay i will i'll be caught up we'll
recap it tomorrow looking forward to it
yes and that is all she wrote do we have
dear toasters
oh [ __ ] sorry yeah totally forgot
geotoast this is our weekly advice
segment since it is wednesday hump day
we are going to be doing deer toasters
where you can write into deertoasters
gmail.com anything anything you want to
tell us we will
read it anonymously we will change
people's names you have a quandary you
need our device on
head over to your toasters at gmail.com
first up
hi claudia and jackie my best friend
recently turned me onto your podcast and
safe to say i'm obsessed i listen to you
every day when i walk my dogs and it's
truly everything of the sort thank you
i need your advice on something i have a
group of friends that i used to work
with that i see a couple times a month
for happy hours and brunches we all went
our separate ways work-wise but still
remain a fun group of friends
we started a tradition a while back that
for everyone's birthday we all pitch in
and get the birthday girl a cute gift
a gift card bottle of wine something
like that well they have not gotten me
something
two years in a row last year i was in
california visiting my parents and
brushed it off trying to be the bigger
person and not be so greedy
this year rolls around and nothing i'm
still trying not to be a greedy little
[ __ ] i didn't say anything
i didn't want to make a big deal about
it or sound like an [ __ ] because i
know they would feel so bad
now we have someone's birthday coming up
in the group and i don't know what to do
a part of me doesn't want to contribute
because it kind of hurts my feelings
that they have forgotten me two years in
a row
but my better half is saying contribute
because you're a good person who would
give without expecting anything in
return
i struggle with that though would love
your advice on this one signed the
birthday snub
that's really tough i think it's
important to give in general without
expecting anything in return but that's
not what this is
don't you dare contribute to that fund
ever again really that's how these
things work
yeah but i feel like it could just be
like a bad coincidence that two years in
a row like she was away and then coveted
like
could it just be a coincidence that you
got forgotten no well you're just
you're gonna make a fight here and like
then things are gonna be awkward so you
have to be prepared to do that
no i i don't don't pay
chip in for the group gift that's
because that's you're being taken
advantage of if you want to get this
girl a gift separately be like i'm
clearly out of the fund because
i have been that's a good idea two years
in a row so this is my personal gift to
you
no that's don't be like walked all over
and
forgotten that's not like if i just was
forgotten twice
are you okay no that's like so messed up
it's like
ever i just that's not how this works
that's not how any of this works but
i like the idea of getting your own gift
being like oh so i'm clearly not a part
of this like
trade anymore so i'm just gonna get my
own gift yeah
don't do it i know but sometimes it's
just like worth the price of admission
just to pay so you don't have to make it
awkward like i'm so controversy
i'm so confrontation averse not
controversy verse i'm actually very
conscious i don't know i think if two
years in a row your friends forgot your
birthday
you'd be knocking on controversy's door
no
contrary contraband
confrontation confrontation yeah no i
was like no i definitely get you
i got controversy a lot i don't get
confrontation a lot controversy knocks
on your door
every day knock knock go away
um okay so good luck with that
good morning scenes i'm in need of some
dire advice so i've been seeing this guy
for about a month and a half
we hang out all the time get along
really well and i think it could be
something really serious eventually
key word is eventually today i was
dropping him off at the airport oh wow
as any good non-girlfriend want to be
possible girlfriend would do
we hoped to say goodbye and i said love
you i said
[ __ ] love you i wish i could
verbalize the level of fear i saw his
eyes as he got out of the car
i tried to backtrack but i was [ __ ]
immediately when i drove away i texted
him basically laughing at myself
to be fair i hadn't had my coffee yet
have dropped off a ton of family and
friends at the airport recently and
truly
like think it was like a weird airport
goodbye review you don't have to explain
it that's something
that would happen to me i say love you
when i'm like making a reservation uh
i used to say love you to my teachers
like yeah let me be very clear i do not
love him i'm still trying to figure out
if i could even date him
here's where i need your help what do i
do now i think i totally scared the [ __ ]
out of him and i don't want to mess this
up because i really care about him do i
continue to just do my thing never speak
of it again
bring it up and try to explain myself or
just move away and start my life over
again
sincerely a girl who didn't have her
coffee i think you just communicate like
be like i literally dropped my mom off
at the airport
last week it's just a reflex i like you
but like we're not there yet and it was
a total accident
yeah i think you can communicate it too
i obviously the
um temptation to like run away and start
all over again is
so tempting and you know what i would
support you but like this is such a
not big deal and i i i feel like it's
like a cute
thing and i think you if he's if he's
meant to be like he will laugh this off
with you you know yeah no and
by the way like can we just talk about
for a second how embarrassing it is to
like say love you
like at the wrong time like yeah to a
waiter or like
a teacher it is so horrifying yeah
so i would just like next time you're
talking on the phone don't put anything
like in
writing because it agreed translated
wrong talk face timing be like by the
way
i didn't mean it in any serious way like
i it was a reflex it's a reflex i say it
to everyone like
don't don't freak out and just make it
like you have that special
yeah i just have my plumber my landlord
my boss and you and you so you're just
one of many
john all right final one hi claudia and
jackie
please help i'm having major drama with
my sister that i can't seem to resolve
my sister is my best friend she's about
four years older than me
but i'm doing a lot of things before her
for example i graduated college at 22
and her at 28.
i got my first job at 23 and her at 29.
i've been in a long-term serious
relationship for six years and her
one and a half i am recently engaged and
will now be getting married in a year
since this things have gotten so weird
between us i am 26 and she is 30.
my fiance and i openly talk about buying
a house soon and having kids shortly
after getting married
my sister is having a hard time being
happy for me she's my maid of honor and
i feel like she doesn't want to be
involved in my wedding
when i ask her for help with something
she has excuses and whenever i talk
about anything wedding related
related she seems weird i understand she
might be bitter but i need her to be
happy for me
we recently had a little argument that
got out of hand and she proceeded to
tell me that i shouldn't be getting
married
and that my fiance and i have a horrible
relationship yes we argue in bicker here
and there but just as any other couple
does
i now feel like when i do have
relationship problems or want to just
vent i can't go to my sister because
she'll hold it over me
or judge my relationship how do i fix
this i can't control how my life is
moving and i just want her to accept it
her time will come that's tough that's
really tough so i think there's a few
things up until you said that like she
has
says she has issues with your fiance i i
mean i can't
like you got married before me got
married before olivia like everything
happens and it's time and so i really
can't
relate to to just being upset about that
part but if she is also having concerns
about your fiance yeah then it becomes
tough you don't want to
share everything but i do think but then
it's like you have a hard time
discerning are these genuine concerns or
you're just like lashing out because
like we're
we're ahead of you right so i think that
one
it is important like and it's kind of
shitty but like every time you have an
issue with your significant other
you can't keep going and telling the
same person especially because it as
humans we tend to only share the
negatives and then when things are good
it's like no news is good news
and you don't share anything so she's
like wait but all these things just
happened
and so it is hard that you sometimes you
like when you're going through it like
either maybe spread out how many people
you're talking to about something
or you sometimes you just have to like
swallow it internally
um but i would maybe like take her to
lunch and have like a big conversation
sometimes in families like you just
gotta talk about something
get to the root of it and maybe what she
her hesitations
are something completely outside of both
of these things right and maybe you're
perceiving it as like her being bitter
but maybe she's like
actually a like dealing with something
on her own like maybe she could use a
sister to talk to about
or maybe she has genuine concerns like i
wouldn't just i wouldn't assume so quick
even though she probably is like bitter
i wouldn't assume so quick that it's
like she's 30 and you're 26 and she's
good and you're getting married
therefore she's like because it's not
like a
a sisterly thing no and also it's not
even that big of a deal like she's 30
and she's also in a relationship like
it it doesn't seem like that would be
the whole thing
um so i would just try and talk to her
about it and also if it is like she has
concerns about your fiance
you need to show her and he if he's the
man that's
obviously listen to her concerns but if
you think that her concerns are
unfounded
show her a different side of him maybe
double date like show her what you
see in him and not just you know venting
to her about all the
fights he got into but this is a a
relationship
worth working on salvaging of course so
i wouldn't let it go
you know unspoken for too long and
because those things fester and then
that's how you end up like
you know 50 years old and haven't spoke
to your sister in 10 years you know yes
which is terrible
no like you guys are stuck together
for better or for worse as it should be
so figure it out it'll be awkward but
then like when you fight with your
sisters like it's awkward for a second
and then you get over it
it's so true um so yeah that was your
toasters
feel like good advice was sold out more
about jackie but dear toasters at
gmail.com you read them beautifully
thank you so much you chanted your
halftorah beautifully if you
want good advice from jackie and me to
make jokes about you
email deartoasters gmail.com we are open
to all sorts of queries
we are and now that's awesome that's all
she wrote
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cast box
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcast find us morning chosen leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are how beautiful
stunning and smart
drops tomorrow morning stay tuned set
your alarms we'll give you all the deets
on our instagram at the morning toast
and you know i'll follow up with some
posts from jack yesterday so you might
want to follow her too yeah cloud with
no job will be participating as well
yes have a great day you guys happy hump
day don't forget to help someone you
love we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
bye